especially I don't like this pen sir
okay I hate your shoes okay
and I don't like your hanging you know
cross here okay
I don't you know this ahead thought it
looks good I love you your hair without
him okay so you hate every song no no
these are foreign name and a society not
where all the time go anywhere he were
too tight front very casual actually is
ready to dance
hence you know I don't like to baggy
don't drop crotch it looks like somebody
coming out from the kitchen
I wish you'd wear more skirts if I Ryan
wake up and then it shows you I'm Pizza
so I hate it
oh you see I'm not excited I am
[Music]
me medium medium medium or small some
what is it too tight I think you lot now
because you know now your your sign it
went up
thanks what size it is actually I looked
much better than this shirt pink baby
pink this is the extent of the pink that
I wear not
yeah like this seam shirt no I don't
want it is it your sides right Johanna's
good yes
oh wow look for work my mom likes it
cause it looks Chinese yeah because we
are trying
oh I love this one I'm trying to believe
he's come orange is orange is the new
black yes
[Music]
now he looks like my son wow you look
handsome my mom wants to know that I can
play tennis
whenever what you're like an insurance
agent cowboy taxi cab driver or like a
cocaine dealer very fine and she just
looks so cute
line on no go running it looks much
better so although she is a girl and not
too baggy because it's it's I like the
tennis because then you're not you like
you know how Serena Williams like this
and then they're like whoa there's a lot
of excess clothing the laser is too
baggy how do you think it's too oh no
it's an obscure wife I always like that
you know become for for pocket they mean
oh I have a lot money
my mom's inner ego is this outfit you
know as much as we disagree on clothes
and it comes down to it I will wear
whatever my mom wants it away and she
pushed me out of her and that sucks more
than me I'm gonna deal with this
ugly-ass jacket hey they give you a lot
lucky money good for here korean king
caps off hair i gotta move how can she
do that like ok leader you liability